yes Annelle 40th reunion was fun and
thinking about that I thought I was very
lucky to be in that show a lot of people
ask me how I got on Saturday live and
although they phrase it more like this
how did you get on sorry Iowa that's
nice but you know I went there early to
kind of rehearse they had a little thing
for me to do with some of the other
weekend update' anchors and I brought my
son he's eight years old you know and we
go into one of the green rooms up by the
studio and I walk in there with him the
afternoon and dirt-eater sitting on the
couch right there cool yeah Larry
David's over there Bob Odenkirk you know
who saw Linda and then Tina Fey sitting
right there I said hey Tina turnout with
Sarah Palin did you really do that okay
with it I thought I was so clever but
then everybody else that came in did the
same joke hey Tina you know yeah so I
set my son down between her chair and
the refrigerator on a bunch of coats and
he was just happy with his iPad right
and Sarah Palin was very nice so I'm
asking about the iPad and what he has
and where did he go to school and how
old he is right and I thought to myself
you know I would never vote for her but
I would hire her as a babysitter
very nice and then you know what I
really want to hear about is the after
party because I've already talked to a
bunch of people who told me the after
party was really a special part of the
evening yeah it was pretty special we go
to the Plaza Hotel and there's a
ballroom in there and a couple different
levels of the party and and I see what's
the Peyton Manning Payton quarterback
for a Denver yeah big guys bigger than
me yeah
bigger than you to it well not me but
yeah smarter smarter smarter than me
more than you and my son's a fan of his
so I thought I'll have my picture taken
maybe he'll take my picture with him and
so I have my picture taken with him and
then he says to his brother Eli Manning
who's standing right over there he says
he like to check the picture see if it's
okay so Eli looks at it my phone says
yeah looks good cuz it's back to me half
hour later I go to to uh text somebody
and I look down on all the fonts are in
Chinese I thought did something like
Manny mess with my phone
I couldn't get out I couldn't do
anything because it's just locked on
Chinese was it was this a a joke that he
played on you I was just maybe it was
that maybe I accidentally hit something
I don't know so then I go upstairs that
will the big party is and then Prince
comes in and he's surrounded by his
entourage yeah I like Prince but I'm not
a huge fan you know I appreciate what he
does right and I see him and we have
icon I go hey Prince how's it going and
he shakes my hand you know and my wife
is there sees the huge fan right and I
go there's my wife Susan she shakes his
hand he leaves and she goes to me he
never touches anybody well he touched us
no I've known that I wouldn't have put
on my hand and then I see paint Manny
over there in the middle of the crowd
higher than everybody he goes hey Neil
him how's your phone so I go where's he
like where's your brother I see you I
said fix this phone I hate the Giant and
you know he pretended to fix it and
still wasn't affixed I had to go down to
the Apple store and I have 15 more
Chinese followers now
[Laughter]
you